Prime Minister last week David Cameron
told the House of Commons the in the
UK's dealings with Iran it is going to
have them I quote a very clear eye and a
very hard heart now UK diplomats here as
regularly given your government
assurances that it is not naive in its
dealings with the Iranians in these
talks why don't you believe them what do
you know that they don't I think the
crucial question is not what we know but
what we seek what we seek is a good deal
or no deal now what's a good deal a good
deal is the one that was done in Syria
in the case of Syria D the chemicals the
materials for weapons and the means to
make the weapons were dismantled and
removed what Iran is seeking from
Britain and the p5 plus one is to keep
the materials and the means to make
nuclear weapons and inspect them keep
and inspect as opposed to dismantle and
remove that's a bad deal and I think
what it would mean is that Iran at any
time could kick the inspectors aside or
deceive them it's done that in the past
and go rush to make the enriched uranium
that is necessary to make atomic bombs
and they can do that within weeks or
months
that's bad for Britain that for Europe
that for the a and I'd say it's bad for
Russia bad for China very bad for Israel
that's for the Arabs too bad for the
world this has been your position for
some time is there any truth in the
Hebrew reports today which is suggesting
you're softening you're approaching that
you would be prepared to see Iran keep
hold of a few hundred centrifuges no I'm
my position from the start has been they
shouldn't have any capacity to enrich
because they don't need it for civilian
nuclear energy they don't need a single
centrifuge it's been the Western
position that they should have a few
hundred now we hear that the p5 plus one
are talking now about 1500 but that's
the spinning centrifuges they say well
maybe they'll have also several thousand
many thousands of centrifuges not
spinning but in formaldehyde sauna or
locked under lock and key okay one day
Iran decides to break the lock and key
breakout is these
put all these thousands of centrifuges
together and they'll have the
wherewithal to make a nuclear bomb in a
very short time
that's a deal that Iran wants it's a
deal of surrender and the p5 plus one
should reject it out of hand they should
not enable Iran to make nuclear weapons
why do you think they haven't rejected
it I think that there has been a theory
that somehow Iran is entitled to
national dignity and national dignity
means that they can make atomic bomb
well serious in title to national
dignity but it's national dignity
doesn't mean that it can have to make
chemical weapons or chemical bombs I
think we have to be clear that we'll
cross a line of history that will
transcend anything else that we're
seeing in the Middle East and God knows
were saying a lot if one of these
warnings said tribes either militant
Sunnis or militant Shiites in this case
the militant Shiites led by Iran get
their hands on nuclear weapons the world
will be forever changed because Iran is
run by an unforgiving sect it puts
forward front men smiling people
reasonable spokesmen like ooh honey but
it's governed with an iron hand and with
an iron heart by this man who will honey
they come in a and I mean he gets
nuclear weapons the world's ultimate
terror regime Iran that sends terrorists
to five continents we'll have the
weapons of ultimate terror they
shouldn't have Tehran is just as
dangerous as you were saying now and as
you have been saying for many years why
hasn't Israel used its right to
unilateral action while you have talked
about before is it because actually
Israel isn't capable of stopping nuclear
programs in Iran on its own well I never
talked about
abilities you know that I'll be the last
Israeli standing never does but I think
what we haven't done is help mobilize
the world to understand the greatness of
this problem and also to launch
sanctions tremendous sanctions against
Iran that have had their effect that's
why Iran is at the table now at the
negotiating table my point is you still
have that tremendous leverage over Iran
because its economy is growing under the
remaining sanctions still growing use it
don't let them have the means to have a
nuclear bomb in a short time when they
are bleeding cash in Iraq they are
bleeding cash in Syria isn't now exactly
the time to push for a diplomatic deal
and a good one the objective is not the
deal the objective is the objective to
make them dismantle their capabilities
why do you have so little confidence in
the West being able to do that
well I hope I hope that that they do do
the right thing that's why I'm giving
this interview among other things and
talking to the United States and Britain
and France and Germany and Russia and
China and we're selling sending
delegations to all these countries to
try to ensure that the deal is a good
one and better No Deal than a bad deal
can I ask one final question in relation
to Hamas clearly the tensions have been
increasing significantly action was
taken in the Gaza Strip overnight is the
next step a military operation of
greater significance inside Gaza is that
your next target for the last well my
first goal is to get these three
teenagers these three innocent boys who
were kidnapped on the way from school to
their parents I want to get them back
home safely
number one and we're continuing our
efforts there second thing is to
dismantle the Hamas infrastructure in
the West Bank and we've done quite a bit
on that we've not sought to engage Hamas
militarily in Gaza but we've been
attacked from Gaza repeatedly so we take
actions to defend ourselves if Hamas
continues to attack or allow attacks
against Israel from Gaza then we will
increase our efforts accordingly do you
think increasing that and playing into
this cycle of violence assists the
efforts to find the missing Israelis do
you risk escalating it as certain
Western governments warned you against
we're trying to contain our efforts to
the search of the three boys but
obviously if we get pounded communities
our towns our cities are pounded by
rockets and missiles that come from from
Gaza control hamas-controlled Gaza will
take action who wouldn't